welcome James it's been a long time
finally here we are the new Bond trailer
is out and this time James Bond faces a
new threat
a terrifying German dude sitting in a
chair I thought Spectre was just an
adorable little singer that's regina
spektor why is regina spektor and James
Bond movie she's not in a James Bond
movie this world makes no sense to me
I'm here to eat spare weather and this
is hashtag news the 24th film the Bond
franchise will hit theaters this
November the story will pick up where
Skyfall left off where James Bond looks
into his past and discovers an evil
organization Hydra wait no that's the
wrong evil organization The Syndicate up
nope wrong again okay these movies are
all pretty much the same aren't they
yeah [ __ ] I don't care take my money
fans me remember Spectre from the
earlier double-oh-seven of the 60s and
70s as the mysterious network of
supervillains headed by arch-nemesis
Blofeld allow me to introduce myself I
am Ernst Stavro Blofeld if he looks
familiar that's because Blofeld is the
villain dr. evil is based on in Austin
Powers
I know if you thought dr. evil was
over-the-top you should see how the real
Bond movies killed off the Blofeld
character right all that because he gets
a better parking spot but this head of
Spectre looks way more serious probably
because he's played by the Christoph
Waltz aka the guy who won an Oscar by
scaring the crap out of us in
Inglourious Basterds other than a few
creepy shots of what looks like Spectre
headquarters this trailer doesn't give
us much action just a bombed out mi6
cool wheels and bond flipping through
his old yearbook voted most likely to
see every woman he sleeps with died but
hey still not a deal-breaker
what's that and then of course there's
this ominous metaphor yeah dancing in a
hurry
Mr Bond you can say any nonsensical
phrase as an old English person and it
will sound really good your kitty cat
dunking on a phony cake Mr Bond oh my
gosh I feel like Queen Elizabeth right
now or Keira Knightley I for one I hope
that we'll get another iconic Lee sexy
scene of Daniel Craig eye candy for the
ladies oh you know the one I'm talking
about girl
he finally let someone in here anyway we
only have seven months until Spectre
comes out so hopefully between now and
then we'll get a real trailer with some
classic Bond images exotic locations
romantic intrigue car chases why won't
you let us show the clips that we should
be showing listen everyone knows what a
Bond movie looks like you will play the
clips that I gave you he's so cute you
guys like this video comment on your
favorite part of the bond trailer and
subscribe to new media rockstars for all
the latest dish I'm gonna use fair
weather and I'm gonna do that cool bond
move where he shaped through a sniper
scope huh oh my god you killed it
pulling it you got a hack up his body
any